bien chers amis bienvenue à tous pour ce
conseil national d'importance est très
attendu monsieur le président cher luc
bravo à tous les candidats qui sont
désormais investi et merci cher
jean-françois pour cette tâche qui
n'était pas facile et qui n'est pas
encore terminée pour laquelle tu as
montré des qualités que nous te
connaissions tu as je crois j'en suis
certaine parfaitement rempli la mission
que françois a confié de constituer pour
lui une majorité solide il y a quelques
semaines françois fillon et je l'en
remercie chaleureusement m'a proposé
d'intégrer l'équipe dirigeante des
républicains comme secrétaire générale
adjointe aux côtés de bernard accoyer
avec gérald darmanin qui a été notre
collègue à l'assemblée nationale jusqu à
ce qu ils ravissent brillamment à la
gauche la mairie de tourcoing j'y
retrouve mes amis vice président
isabelle le callennec laurent wauquiez
et notre trésorier daniel fasquelle
nous avons donc sous la responsabilité
bernard la tâche de mettre notre
mouvement en ordre de marche pour les
deux élections majeures qui nous
attendent que notre pays espèrent tant
ce gouvernement calamiteux la mise à mal
pour ceux comme moi qui viennent de
vivre ce mandat dans l'opposition vous
n'imaginez pas à quel point nous avons
souffert pour notre pays
au fil des lois mauvaise des lois
délétère qui ont été voter malgré notre
mouvement a toujours été d'une
efficacité extraordinaire pour conduire
des batailles
c'est dans notre adn soumis à l'exercice
inédits des primaires il n'a pas tardé à
se remettre en ordre de marche car nous
sommes tendus vers un seul objectif
capelle notre sens des responsabilités
l'alternance avec la victoire de
françois fillon
merci merci à nicolas à alain à bruno à
nathalie à jean frédéric à jean-françois
pour leur fair-play et leur loyauté
applaudissons l'est également
avec gérald est en accord avec bernard
accoyer notre secrétaire général nous
nous sommes réparti la tâche à gérald
les fédérations mais il vous
l'expliquera et pour moi chers amis
candidat la constitution d'un pôle
d'appui aux candidats aux élections
législatives
je veux que nos 577 candidats
particulièrement les primo candidats
puissent trouver auprès des républicains
une oreille toujours attentive des
ressources et des conseils que ce soit
en matière pratiques juridiques
financières mais surtout surtout
politique
ce poids est capital car chacun de vous
sera le relais de françois fillon sur le
terrain notre victoire aux législatives
découle en grande partie de celle de
notre candidat je dirais même qu'elle ne
prend son sens qu'avec la victoire de
françois fillon à la présidentielle et
vous verrez chers amis jusqu'à la
présidentielle c'est de françois qu on
vous parlera de son programme de son
projet de notre projet et il faudra que
vous soyez en mesure d'en parler tout
comme vous devrez expliquer ce qu'a été
la gestion catastrophique de françois
hollande et de ces gouvernements
nous vous fournirons des argumentaires
et je réfléchis à la mise en oeuvre très
prochainement avec les clips des
républicains à des formations très
opérationnelle maintenant que les
candidats sont investis pour la plus
grande part nous allons pouvoir sans
tarder leur proposer ces formations mes
chers amis candidats je veux vous redire
tout mon soutien et mes voeux de
réussite
le mandat de député est un très beau
mandat un mandat passionnant
élu en 2012 je serai candidate comme
vous à vos côtés je vous souhaite de
tout coeur de connaître ce bonheur je
vous aiderai de mon mieux
avec notre équipe est en lien avec les
fédérations dont je voudrais saluer les
présidents et les secrétaires
départementaux très nombreux ce matin
alors chers amis en route et pas en
marche
en route pour porter françois fillon à
la victoire et lui donner une belle et
franche majorité à l'assemblée nationale
[Applaudissements]